have you heard of the save ima norway
masjid project your brothers and sisters
at islam that are establishing a one of
his kind masjid tawa and community
center in the capital of norway and they
need our urgent support now every person
that accepts islam through this center
every revert who learns about their deen
and calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video there was a
night where i couldn't sleep here
and um probably like four in the morning
so i get out my bed and i'm like you
know let me let me start praying
[Music]
salaam alaikum welcome to a better
career brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys will inshallah
brother and sisters as you guys know um
aj
who is also known as anthony joshua so
he's got a boxing match coming very soon
inshallah um in saudi arabia so he's
been there and a reporter asked him a
very very important question and he gave
a very very unique answer to it very
interesting he doesn't really claim if
he's a muslim or not but he says
something very interesting you know even
if you're a believer or not a believer
he says that sometimes when he's at the
gym sometimes i don't have to you use
the word nervous but he says sometimes
he can't sleep so because of that they
he hears the adhan the quote of prayer
and i think he's joined some of his
friends um you know he has a lot of
muslim friends um for fajr very
interesting problem so panel if you can
think if you think about it i've
recently come across a lot of
non-muslims who are actually
they they want to try and i can believe
when i first was looking into islam i
used to fast i used to try to fast i
wanted to know what fasting was about so
it's something that is close to my heart
as well because i wanted to see what's
the fasting about etc you only truly
understand the sweetness when you become
a believer because usually as a
disbeliever when you fast you're just
like okay i'm staying away from food why
am i staying with fruit i don't know
just to try it fasting prayer and the
things that you do actions
are greater and it has a sweetness to it
when you inshallah like do it for the
sake of allah but it's very interesting
that anthony joshua anthony joshua would
want to go and wake up for fajr which is
one of the most hardest uh prayers
brother sisters yeah what does that say
about us how many muslims are watching
this and they do not wake up for fajr
and you anybody that comes to me and
says i can't wake up i'm
i'm tired um
my life is busy in a nutshell what
you're trying to say is this it's as if
the bella you're saying that your lord
who created the heavens and the earth
was not aware that when he sent and bear
in mind why he came down by the angel
gabriel to the prophet muhammed peace be
upon him but when it came to the issue
of salah the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him had to go to the heavens and
meet allah and we don't know if he saw
allah subhanahu wa we do not know but
he had to go there and get
the um
the ruling when it comes to salah which
shows how important it is brothers and
sisters while you're trying to say to
yourself you do not wake up for salah is
the following allah doesn't know my
affairs that i'm going to be busy in the
worldly things and he has told me to do
something that i can't do
this is borderline it can be comfortable
i'm not saying you become a disbeliever
but the thought of it that allah is
telling you to do something and not
aware what an insult to him if i go to
my son and say or my daughter i want you
to do and they're like i can't do it
what they're basically trying to say to
me is like as if i don't know that they
can't do it and i am making them do
something they can't do no allah knows
very well we can do it you have 24 hours
a day
five minutes anthony joshua who is i
don't know if he's believed or not
if he's a disbeliever for him to wake up
for fajr and for you not to let me tell
you something it's a matter of priority
if i came to you and i said i will give
you five thousand pounds which i don't
have if i had it and i would maybe lend
it to you
to wake up for five minutes
you will set 27 alarms you will ring
your neighbor and say if i don't wake up
bang the door smash the door you will
tell your wife to wake you up you will
do everything in your power why for 5
000 pounds
so it's a matter of priority but when
your lord is promising you
janna what is 5000 pounds and you say
what
tired no no no you're not tired you are
not tired it's a matter of priority it's
a matter of iman it's fine when i first
came to islam i found it very hard to
wake up fajr the first year i made dua i
asked allah please and wallahi allah
made it easy for me i'm just going to
wrap up on that but from anthony joshua
we can learn a key lesson if him i don't
know if he's a muslim or not but let's
assume that he's not if he can go and go
to prayer
and wake up for fajr oh
you know what let me go and pray
how could it be that we're in muslim
households where your mom and dad is a
muslim not like
people who are families are not muslim
and while they wake up
look i don't know what to feel sorry for
me i would sometimes tiptoe tiptoe in my
house so my my dad doesn't hear me
waking up for fajr
how is it that you're in a household
where your mom and dad is begging you to
pray that's all i'm going to say brother
and sisters let this be a reminder and
set your alarms setting your alarms is a
gold it's good it means you are now
striving to wake up set your alarm even
if you don't wake up you know that you
set your alarm for fajr
initially you'll get the ajar until next
time assalamu alaikum foreign